Hi.
I'm eating.
I'm eating right now.
Hold on.
One more little noodle.
Mmm.
Um...
Sorry.
I didn't know you could see that.
Why is there a box on my face?
And the karaoke box over the...
Stop it!
Stop looking!
Actually, I think I need to do the...
You know what?
Screw you guys.
Are we ready to be nice now?
Are we ready?
Ta party!
Woo woo!
Karaoke time!
Yippee!
Um, I don't know what to sing at all!
I don't know what to sing at all!
I have like no list at all.
We're singing whatever we want, baby.
Some things, if they're not on Karofan, I can probably find
them on YouTube, so.
And Draco, thanks for the 10 gift too!
Country roads!
Aksdf too, thanks for the 20 gift too!
you know what let's start with a little country roads
warm-up country roads take me home i'll do this as a test
sound test too because oh no no oh my god so in my almost
heaven
mountains Shenandoah River life is old they're older than
the trees younger than the mountains blowing like a breeze
country roads take me home to the place I belong West
Virginia Mountain Mama Take me home Country roads All my
memories Gather round her Miners ladies Stranger to blue
water Stay hydrated everybody Dark and dusty Painted on the
sky Misty taste of moonshine Teardrop in my eye Country
roads Take me home To the place I belong West Virginia
Mountain Mama Take me home Country roads I hear her voice in
the morning hour she calls me.
The radio reminds me of my home far away.
Driving down the road, I get a feeling that I should have
been home yesterday.
Yesterday.
Country roads.
Take me home to the place.
I belong West Virginia Mountain Mama Take me home Country
roads One more time Country roads Take me home To the place
I belong West Virginia Mountain Mama, take me home.
Country rolls, take me home.
Da-da!
Yee-a-ya-ya-ya-ya-ya-ya-ya-ya-ya-ya-ya-ha.
Yee-ha, everybody.
Yee-ha.
How was the audio on the, oh wait, I forgot to do a set
list.
One, country roads.
Actually, I don't want it on the, let's do it to the left.
To the left, to the left.
Everything you own in a box to the left.
Audio's perfect, audio's good, sounds great.
Yee-ha, partner.
Yee-yup.
My, um, you might have looked and might have found here
today.
Can you sing in Kermit voice?
What would you want me to sing in Kermit voice?
Healing my soul.
I'm going to move you guys over a little bit.
Actually, I'm going to move you guys right here.
Yay.
Yep.
And also, I'm going to block how many people are watching.
I usually do, but the way I had it before.
California girls.
California girls by Katie Perry as sung by Kermit Voice
Okay, um, okay, I think you can do this Greetings, loved
ones Greetings, let's take a drink I know a place where the
grass is really greener.
Warm, wet and wild.
There must be something sipping gin and juice, laying
underneath the palm trees.
The boys break their necks, try to creep a little sneak
peek.
Travel the world, but nothing comes close to the golden
coast.
Once you party with Frog Bird, you'll be falling in love.
Oh, oh, oh.
California Frogs were unforgettable.
Daisy Duke's bikinis on top.
Sun-kissed skins so hot will melt your popsicle.
Oh, oh, oh.
Outlit cornea frogs, we're undeniable, fine, fresh, fierce.
We got it on luck.
West Coast represent, put your hands up.
Beach, why is it so bright?
We don't mind sand in our stilettos.
We freak in my Jeep.
Snoop doggie dog on the stereo.
Oh, oh, you could travel the world.
But nothing comes close to the golden coast.
Once you party with frog birds, you'll be falling in love.
California frogs were unforgettable.
Daisy dukes, bikinis on top.
Sun kiss getting so hot, we'll melt your popsicle.
Oh, oh, oh.
California girls, we're on the night.
reliable, fine, fresh, fierce, we got it on lock, West
Coast, represent, now put, I don't remember how the song
goes, I'm just listening to the harmony, tone 10, fat and
ready, wait, no,
it's my beaches, though, because I'm such a sweet, sure,
it's a neat family,
when it's beach in Palm Springs, summertime is everything,
homeboys banging out, all that hanging out.
Bikinis, wikinis, martinis, no weenies, just the king and
the queenie.
Katie, my lady, look here.
Oh, look here, baby, I'm all up on you because you represent
in California.
Daisy Duke's bikinis on top.
Sun-kissed skin so hot.
We'll melt your popsicle.
Oh, oh, oh.
California girls were undeniable.
Fine, fresh, fierce.
We got it.
I'm back.
West Coast for a person.
Now put your head.
There's only a few children who would do what we do.
I think I lost.
I think I got lost in the sauce there a little bit.
No, I messed up the best part.
I'm so sorry.
One second.
I think I'm going to turn the glow down just a little bit.
So you guys don't keep getting flashbangs when it...
shows of oh my god that was california frogs popsicle status
melted california frogs my throat is don't tan fat and ready
like me and their frogs right they gotta get um frogs out
well not in the summertime they in the winter time don't
they hibernate Hmm.
Okay.
Thank you for karaoke on my birthday.
Happy birthday, Casey Raptor!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, Casey Raptor.
Okay.
Maybe cloudy and rainy out, but mint singing is all the
sunshine I need for my song.
What else can we do?
Oh my gosh, the world is our oyster.
We could sing whatever we want.
Trooper by Iron Maiden.
I'm sorry I don't know it well enough.
Please don't spam, though.
If you want me to sing a song, if you spam it, it's going to
be even less likely.
I sing it.
You're a stream.
Oh!
There's a...
Sorry, the notives.
This is the fat and ready content.
Oh, that's so funny.
Let's see.
The title of the stream is English song.
Kermit, fat and ready.
you oh man golden hour already oh my gosh let me warm up a
little bit first let me let me warm up a little bit but i'm
fat and ready for frogbert to be my yoshi paramore oh gosh
what do i know by paramore i know maybe paramore
Oh, yes, Golden Hour.
I could try.
I'm saying Snow Halation has about five English words.
Now I could sing the Triple Q version.
Is it Misery Business?
Is the one that I was...
I don't think I know it well enough, though.
Do they have...
have duvet duvet is that how you say it oh my gosh they do
okay i can sing that one later i want to do a little bit
more mumbo number five mumbo
mumbo number five ladies
and gentlemen this is mumbo number five
i one two three four five everybody in the car so come on
let's ride to the Liquor store around the corner, the boys
say they want some gin and juice, but I really don't want to
be a buzz.
Like I had last week, I must stay deep because talk is
cheap.
I like Angela, Pamela, Sandra, and Rita.
And as I continue, you know they're getting sweeter.
So what can I do?
I don't know how the song is turning.
It's just like a sport.
Anything's right.
It's all good.
Let me jump in and send in the trumpet.
A little bit of Monica in my life.
A little bit of Erica on my other side.
A little bit of Rita's all I need.
A little bit of Tina's what I see.
A little bit of Sandra in the sun.
A little bit of Mary on I
and me.
Wait, you makes me your man.
Jump up and down and move it all around.
Shake your head to the sound, put your hands on the ground.
Take one step left and one step right.
One to the front and one to the side.
Clap your hands one.
Monica in my life.
A little bit of A little bit of Rita's all I need.
A little bit of Tina's what I see.
A little bit of Sandra in the sun.
A little bit of Minto.
Oh no, wait, that's all this time.
It's an endurance stream, that's why.
You're mad, ha!
Drop it!
Put
up on my side.
A little bit of Rita's all I need.
A little bit of Tina's what I see A little bit of Sandra in
the sun A little bit of Mary all night long A little bit of
Jessica, here I am A little bit of you makes me your man To
all two fall in love with a girl like you Cause you can't
run and you can't hide You and me gonna touch the sky That's
kind of scary What do you mean I can't run or hide
I'm kind of scared now
Yeah Mambo Mambo Number five Four
The song is a threat Monica, Erica, Rita, Tina, Sandra, Mary
and Jessica All me
Sing Jolene!
Oh my gosh, Jolene, Jolene, Jolene, Jolene.
I can try.
Dolly Parton.
I think I remember this one.
I think I.
Fleetwood Mac.
Oh yeah, we can do some later.
Jolene, Jolene, Jolene, Jolene.
Love you, please don't take my Mac.
Jolene, Jolene, Jolene, Jolene, please don't take thank you
just because you can.
Your beauty is beyond compare with flaming locks of all
burnt hair with ivory skin and eyes of emerald green.
Your smile's like a breath of spring, your voice is soft
like some And I cannot compete with you, Jolene.
He talks about you in his sleep.
There's nothing I can do to keep from crying when he calls
your name, Jolene.
And I can easily understand how you could easily take my
man, but you don't know what he means to me.
Jolene.
Jolene, Jolene, Jolene, I'm begging of you, please don't
take my man.
Jolene, Jolene, Jolene, Jolene, please don't take him just
because you can.
You could have your choice of men, but I could never love
again.
He's the only one for me.
Is that a JoJo reference?
Actually, the other way around.
My happiness depends on you and whatever you decide to do.
Jolene.
Jolene, Jolene, Jolene, Jolene.
I'm begging of you, please don't take my man.
Jolene, Jolene, Jolene.
Jolene, please don't take him even though you can.
Jolene.
Damn, hit it girl.
That's a Dolly Parton reference.
Jolene, Jolene, Jolene.
Oops.
Jolene.
From JoJo's Bizarre Adventure.
This too is Yuri.
I mean, Jolene, she sounds like, I don't know, I can't tell
if she's like, um, if she's gonna take the, if she's like
interested in the guy or if she's like, you know, Moana!
I was just thinking I want to sing Disney songs.
Um, oh my god, I sang this all the time when I was in Japan.
I can't tell if she's like trying to take her take the guy
or if she's just like no I know you can do it but like
please don't but also this guy sounds like a jerk he's the
one who's like saying her name in his sleep what a weirdo
what a weirdo oh I don't remember which one it is if it's
the original one or if it's the I'm gonna try this one if
it's the wrong one if it's like the, if it's like the poppy
version, I'll change.
Break stuff by Limp Biscuit.
Patience.
I've been staring at the edge of the water, long as I can
remember.
Never really knowing why.
I wish I could be the perfect But I come back to the water,
no matter how hard I try.
Every turn I take, every trail I track, every path I make,
every road leads back to the place I know where I cannot go,
where I long to be.
See the line where the sky meets the sea, it calls me.
And no one knows how far it goes.
If the wind in my sail on the sea stays behind me One day
I'll know If I go, there's just no telling how far I'll go I
know everybody on this island Seems so happy on this island
Everything is by design I know everybody on this island on
this island so maybe i can roll with mine i can lead with
pride i can make us strong i'll be satisfied if i play along
but the voice inside sings a different song what is wrong
with me see the light as it shines on the sea it's blinding
but no one knows how deep it goes And it seems like it's
calling out to me, so come find me, and let me know what's
beyond that line, will I cross that line?
See the line where the sky meets the sea, it calls me, and
no one knows how far it goes.
If the wind and my sail on the sea stays behind me One day
I'll know how far I'll go
Wow Wow This song makes me tear up every time
Wow Makes me so emotional how far I'll go because I relate
to the lyrics so much I don't know it's hard to explain
Disney Disney Disney what's another Disney Disney I won't
say I'm in love I won't say I'm in love boo-doo boom boom
wait well there's a longer version of the song I don't know
it though
if there's There's a price for rotten judgment I guess I've
already won that No man is worth the aggravation That's
ain't in history Been there, done that Don't you think
you're kidding He's the yours that ever do You try to keep
it hidden Honey, we can see Oh no We know how you feel
Oh, no chance, no way, I won't say it no, no Yes, oh, yes I,
why deny?
Oh, it's too cliche, I won't say I'm in love I thought my
heart had learned its lesson It feels so good when you start
out My head is screaming, get a grip, girl Unless you're
dying to cry your heart out.
You keep on denying who you are and how you're feeling.
Baby, we're not buying harm.
We saw your hip was sealed.
Face it like a grown up when you're kind of honored that you
don't.
Cause, cause.
Oh, no chance, no way.
I won't say you don't know.
Give up, give and check the green.
You're in love.
You'll see who won't play.
I won't say I'm in love.
Your way off your face, I won't say it Get off my case, I
won't say it Girl, don't be proud, it's okay
Well, at least I'll love I won't say I'm in love
I should have had this, I should have, I should have I
should have been like this the whole time baby don't you
don't deny it we know how you're how oh my gosh i saw
someone else say something actually i'm just gonna do a
medley maybe um won't say i'm in love oh my gosh you know
what's so funny before my stream yesterday with i amy sense
When we were when we were talking, we met about
Oh my god, oh my
Thank you for singing for us tonight I hope you can sing
some Disney songs tonight, but no Wow virulent I think
you're maybe Psychic
What was I gonna say um what was i gonna say oh when we were
like talking to when we were talking with each other i was
like i was still preparing um obs and she was just like it's
okay take your time and i was just like she was just like we
can tell them that will be a little bit late and i was like
yeah you know um they'll just start crying and she was just
like yeah and then when it got time to start the stream and
everybody started crying and then she was just like oh it's
time should we are you almost ready i was like yeah i'm
almost ready just maybe a few more minutes um are they
crying and she was like oh she looked she's like oh they
really are they really are crying it was so funny yeah um we
were talking about silly stuff um i won't be streaming for
the next couple of days um so i'll I don't know how long
today's stream will be.
We'll stream until my voice gives out.
But I also need to get ready as well.
But we'll...
We'll...
We'll... We'll sing until I cannot sing anymore.
So I'm gonna sing more Disney.
This song I've never sung before, but I really love this
song.
So I think I'm gonna up the key.
Like a little, maybe two.
Let's see how it goes.
Save behind its windows and these parapets of stone Gazing
at the people down below me Oh, there's a little high about
somewhere Hold on Before the histories they show me That's
kind of low Light from the faces Knowing them as they will
never know me Maybe I do need to lower the key Hold on, I'm
going to lower the key They all just try singing it normal
Safe behind these windows and these parapets of stone Gazing
at the people down below me All my life I watch them as I
hide up here alone Hungry for the history as they show me
All my life I memorize their faces Knowing them as they will
never know me I don't know how it feels as if it's not above
them but part of them and out there living in the sun give
me one day out there all I ask is one to hold forever out
there where they all live on What I'd give What I dare Just
to live But one day out there
Out there among the millers and the weavers and the wives
Through the roofs and cables I can see them Every day they
shout and scold and go about their lives Heathless of the
gift it is to be them If I was in their skin, I treasure
every instant.
Out there, strolling by the sun, taste of mourning.
Out there, like ordinary men who freely walk up.
Fell there just one day and then I swear I'll be content
With my share Won't resent, won't despair Hold and mend, I
won't care All has spent Why?
Oh God, hey, hello there
I was not prepared for that oh my I was not prepared oh my
god oh I'm sorry my voice cracked in that one part I was so
sorry my voice cracked I was not right I am in awe bravo oh
my gosh me being like I don't want to sing some of harder
songs yeah i need to warm my voice up first sheesh okay this
part this next song
i'm gonna skip the beginning i'm gonna skip to here
speaking of hell how about hellfire my way ahead of you
You know I am a righteous man of my virtue, I am justly
proud.
Beata Maria, you know I'm so much purer than the common
vulgar weak licentious crowd.
Then tell me, Maria, why I see her dancing there, why her
smoldering eyes still scorched my soul.
I feel her, I see her, the sun caught in her raven hair Is
blazing in me out of all control Like fire, hellfire, this
fire in my skin This burning desire is turning me to sin
it's not my fault I'm not to blame it is the gypsy girl the
witch who sent this flame it's not my fault if in God's plan
he made the devil so much stronger than a man protect me
Maria don't let this siren cast her spell don't let her fall
Fire, sear my flesh and bone.
Destroy Ismerelda!
And let her taste the fires of hell, or else let her be mine
and mine alone.
Minister Frollo, the gypsy has escaped.
Who are you?
Get out of my room.
She's nowhere in the cathedral.
No, what?
Oh my god.
But how?
Um, go get my girlfriend back.
I'll find her if I have to burn down all of Paris.
Hellfire, dark fire.
Now Gypsy, it's your turn.
Choose me your, your fire.
Be mine or you will burn.
God have mercy on her.
God have mercy on me.
But she will be mine or she will burn.
Yeah!
That song fills me with so much passion.
You know what, that's a go out there and get her guys kind
of song, isn't it?
go out there that's a go-getter song
that's a yeah no it's not
oh my gosh villain songs are always so good right except oh
my gosh I really dislike the one from wish I don't remember
what how it even goes actually okay you guys give me a
second you know that I recently got a standing desk and I
stream i hope when i use this it doesn't turn off my
computer i'm like worried that it's gonna like short circuit
i'm gonna stand oh okay i'm lifting up my desk i'm lifting
up my desk oh how high can this go whoa okay nice standing
time oh my gosh i have so much room to dance i'm a little
room oh no i'm gonna be so much more obnoxious now because
I'm going to be actually, like, dancing around.
Yeah.
I'm going to be dancing around for real.
Give me one second.
What is going on here?
Okay, there we go.
Make sure my phone's not on.
Okay.
What's the next song?
Actually, you know what?
Can I do a Hunchback and Rotterdam's song?
Are Hololive songs off-limits for legal reasons?
No, but...
Hold on, I'm also going to move my mic up.
Oh, setlist, thank you.
Out there.
And Hellfire.
Boy, it's one word.
But a lot of the Hololive songs are in Japanese.
And this is...
This is in English.
Oh, Sparks?
Wait.
Is there even a karaoke for Sparks?
Sparks Instrumental.
I'm not going to bother Kiara.
Wait, Kiara.
Oh my god!
Wait.
There is one.
Wait, it says karaoke for instrumental with lyrics.
Oh, I could.
Hmm.
you might be there.
Do you?
I don't know if I could sing them well, but I'll try.
Maybe later.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, one more hunchback of Notre Dame song.
I'm sorry.
Wait, is it this one?
I'll do the shorter one.
I think it's the shorter one.
Danielle, welcome to membership.
And thank you guys for all the super chats, too.
I'll make a man out of you.
Yes.
make a man out of you, no worries.
We'll do more Disney.
Sorry, I'm a Disney fan.
I don't want to say the Disney adult, that's embarrassing,
right?
I don't know if you can hear me, or if you're even there.
I don't know if you will listen to a humble prayer.
They tell me I'm just an outcast.
I shouldn't speak to you Still I see your face and wonder
Were you once an outcast too?
God help the outcasts Hungry from work Show them the mercy
They don't find on earth The lost and forgotten They look to
you still God help the outcast Or nobody will Why does it
sound like the ending version?
It sounds different I ask for nothing I can get by But I
know so many Less lucky than mine God help me outcast the
poor and downtrodd I thought we all were the children of God
Listen, some are, some are not Why the few you seem to favor
Outcast the tatters the heart torn seeking an answer to why
they were born winds of misfortune have blown them about you
made the outcast don't cast them out I'm confused the poor
and unlucky the weak and the odd that's me i thought we all
were i'm sorry so it's children of god
i'm sorry i'm so unserious i'm the odd
okay i'm not even gonna put that on this set list i was so
confused during that i don't i thought i picked the shorter
version because there's also a longer version but i don't
remember the other parts of the okay I love Hunchback of
Notre Dame it's such an awesome movie there's a karaoke of
the original version out there I'm sure there is but oh
let's see do you still remember the requests there were a
ton what do you mean remember there were there were so many
requests Tarzan songs I don't know very many Tarzan songs
because I didn't watch a lot of Tarzan
Kendrick Kendrick Lamar song I don't even know that guy Has
been Hotel Those songs have bad words In it Has been Hotel
There's only actually one song from Has been Hotel That I've
listened to And it's I don't remember what it was called
Stayed Gone No It was the song between I don't know I've
never watched it It's the song between between the radio guy
and the TV guy.
Kevin Lamar.
Oh, who's that?
Who is that?
Wait, who's that?
StadeCon?
I was right.
Oh my god, I'm scared though.
I'm showing the screen.
It says bad word.
It's going to show up.
Fulamoko rivals.
That's the guy.
Who's Ken then?
Kevin Lamar is what Fulamoko called.
Wait, so his name is actually Kevin.
Kevin.
His actual name is Kendrick.
Oh.
I see, I always thought they were two different people
because they were talking.
I've only seen, I've seen Kendrick Lamar and I've seen Kevin
Lamar.
I thought they were two different people.
I was like, wow, there's a lot of rappers with the last name
Lamar.
Wow.
I was like, wow, I didn't realize Lamar was such a popular
last name.
Is this a bit?
I'm never serious.
What are you talking about?
Of course this is a bit.
Things are the peak.
Your unique voice and personality elevates every song you
sing.
Sing your heart out.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Lamar isn't his last name.
What?
What does it mean?
Is it like a...
type of juice?
Bum, bum, bum, bum.
Please wrap it up.
Shut up!
Oh, it's a middle name!
His last name is actually Duxworth.
No, it's not.
Kevin Lamar Duxworth.
Duxworth is a song by...
Oh, no, Kendrick Lamar.
Wait.
It is.
It's real.
Okay.
It's actually his last name.
Hold on.
Song by Kendrick Lamar taken from his album.
Dang.
The song's title is Lamar's actual last name.
What?
Who is Kendrick Lamar?
Oh.
He's just some guy.
I would also go No, he should have gone by Duck's word
That's so much cooler That's so much cooler
What do you mean some guy?
I don't know, I'm just looking at him He just looks like a
guy Am I looking at the right person?
Oh wait, sorry, I typed Kevin Kendrick Lamar Actually, I'm
going to look up Kevin Duck's worth.
That's just, yeah.
Okay.
It'd be kind of weird if he looked like a ghost.
I'm not expecting him to look like a ghost.
I'm just, I don't know.
I don't know what I'm expecting.
Minto karaoke on my birthday, Marty!
Happy birthday!
Could you sing happy birthday?
It would be if my Kabayoshi sang it.
Was it my first Supa worth it?
Thank you!
Yeah, I kind of expected a duck.
To be honest Happy birthday to you Happy birthday to you
Happy birthday dear Marty With extra wisy Happy birthday to
a you
His dad's nickname was actually Ducky I wonder if this is on
here.
Life
is like a hurricane here in Duckburg.
Race cars, lasers, aeroplanes.
It's a duck blur.
Might solve a mystery or rewrite history.
Duck tales.
Every day they're out there making DuckTales!
When it seems they're heading for The final curtain Cool
deduction never fails That's for certain The worst of messes
Become successes DuckTales!
Every day they're out there making DuckTales!
There's a stranger out to find you What to do?
Just grab on to some duck tails
oh my god
yay yay
thank you for singing the song of my people I got you duck
tails oh I was jumping all around the whole song oh wait did
I do anything between hellfire and oh yeah duck tails duck
tails oh oh
basically like doing jumping jacks all the time because I'm
like flapping my head.
Woo, woo!
Okay, that was so fun, yo.
I'll one day sing it, maybe with 3D.
It's my birthday too, which means it's karaoke specifically
for me now since I am announcing it after the other guy.
Timmo!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Timmo!
Happy birthday to you.
How about some Little Mermaid for your newest subscriber?
Second newest now.
Little Mermaid I can do.
Little Mermaid.
Which song from the Little Mermaid?
What song should I do from the Little Mermaid?
I can do all of them.
No, I'm just kidding.
Under the sea.
Okay.
I'm gonna start dancing again.
You guys just want me to dance.
Uh...
The seaweed is always greater.
It's somebody else's lake.
You got me...
You got there.
But then...
Can I show you guys...
Can I show you how I feel when I'm singing these?
hold on i have to get i have to get a tick tock that i sent
to matara but um but it's actually maybe me i sent it to her
i was like this is you but maybe it's me okay hold on hold
on uh where is it i said this is you oh i'm gonna put it on
the screen and then you can just imagine me it looking like
this while i'm while i'm singing Okay, okay, but hold on.
I have to make sure you don't hear the audio.
Can I just...
Oh, download video.
Oh, my God, I can just download the video.
Oh, wait.
It's going to play the audio, though.
I don't want you to hear the audio.
Let's see.
How do I do this?
Maybe like this.
And then...
How do I do this?
I should turn the air on in my...
In my maid cafe.
It's so warm.
You did it?
It's gonna play immediately.
I'm scared.
Oh wait, yeah.
Oh shoot, how do I do this?
Sorry.
Sorry for...
Can we have to stream for a minute?
No, it's because...
OBS is kind of messing me up right now.
Okay, hold on.
I got this.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Kind of.
Maybe.
No, I just want to show you guys the silly video.
Oh, I just want to show you the silly video.
Just want to show you the silly video.
Maybe audio filter.
okay hold on maybe i can do gain and then lower entirely so
that there's nothing that plays okay i'm really sorry if you
hear this i'm really sorry
okay okay i'm just gonna put it right here okay this is me
this is me as i'm as i'm singing
were trying to imagine music it's caramel dancing
the seaweed is always greener than somebody else's lake you
dream about going up there but that is a big mistake just
look at the world around you right here on the ocean floor
such wonderful things around you what more is you looking
for under the sea under the sea darling it's better Down
where it's wetter, take it from me Up on the shore, they
work all day Out in the sun, they serve a wave While we
devote in full time to floating under the sea Ha ha ha ha ha
ha Toytle Down here all the fish is happy As all through the
waves they roll The fish on the land ain't happy They sad
cause they in their pool But fish in the pool is lucky They
aim for a worse of faith.
One day when the boss gets hungry, guess who got me on the
play?
Uh-oh!
Under the sea!
Nobody beat us fries and eat us and fries.
What would we learn to food and cook under the sea?
We're off the hook!
We got no troubles.
Life is the bubbles!
Under the sea!
Since life is sweet here, we got the here naturally.
Even the surgeon and the ray, they get the urge and start to
play.
We've got the spirit, you've got to hear it under the sea.
The flute, the cart play the harp, the place play the bass
and bass sound and sharp.
The bass play the brass and drum play the tub.
The fluke is the duke of soul, yeah.
The ray he can play, the lings on the strings, the trout
rocking out, the black
that blowfish glow!
Oh yeah, I can't hear you.
Oh no!
...
Maybe a standing desk was a mistake.
Whoa!
Under the sea!
When the sardine begin the begweenies, Music to me Wonder
they got a lot of sand We got a hot Crescention fan Each
little clam here know how to jam here Under the sea Each
little slug here Cutting a rug here under the sea Each
little sail here know how to wail here That's why it's
hotter Under the water Yeah we in luck here Down in the muck
here Under the sea
Yeah!
That's me.
That was me the entire song, that little kid.
Even the, including the falling on the floor and everything.
Yay!
Be my guest.
Oh, be my, be our guest.
Be our guest.
Got me grooving and laughing at work.
Didn't mute it.
This one.
Be our guest.
Le Poisson?
Le Poisson, le Poisson.
Something, something, le Poisson.
My chrie, mademoiselle, it is with deepest pride and
greatest pleasure that we welcomed you tonight.
And now we invite you to relax.
Let us pull up a chair as the dining room presents, or
proudly presents, your dinner.
Be our guest, be our guest.
Put our service to the test.
Tie your napkin round your neck, Sherry, and we'll provide
the rest.
Soup de jour, hot de du bou, how do we only live to serve.
Try the great stuff, it's delicious.
Don't believe me, ask the dishes.
They can sing, they can dance.
After all, Miss, this is France, and a dinner here is never
second best.
Go on, unfold your men, you take a glance, and then you'll
be.
We are guests, we are guests, we are guests, be our guest.
Beer, arugue cheese souffle, pie and pudding on flamb.
We'll prepare and serve with flair a culinary cabaret.
You're alone and you're scared, but the banquet's all
prepared.
No one's gloomy or complaining while the flatware's
entertaining.
We tell jokes, I do tricks with my fellow candlesticks.
And it's all in perfect taste that you can bear.
Come on and list your glass You won your own free pass Don't
be our guest If you're stressed It's fine dining we suggest
Be our guest Be our guest Be our guest Life is so unnerving
For a servant who's not serving He's not whole Without a
soul to wait upon It's just like me I'm a maid Ah the good
old days when we were useful I don't remember this part
Suddenly Those good old days are gone.
Ten years we've been rusting, needing so much more than
dusting, needing exercise, a chance to use our skills.
Most days we just lay around the castle.
Flabby fat and lazy, you walked in and oopsie daisy!
It's a guest, it's a guest, sake's alive, I'll be blessed.
Wine's been poured and thank the Lord I had the napkins
freshly pressed.
She'll want tea.
And my dear, that's fine with me.
While the cups do their soft shoe and I'll be glovin' I'll
be blah, blah, blah.
Heaven's sake is not a spot.
Clean it up.
We want the company impressed.
We've got a lot to do.
Is it one lump or two?
For you our guest, be our guest.
She's our guest.
Be our guest.
A command is your request.
It's been here since we've had anybody here and we're
outside.
Yes, with your meal, with your ease.
Yes, indeed, we aim to please.
While the candlelight's still glowing, let us help you.
We'll keep going.
Horse by course.
Oh, one by one.
Oh, till you shout, oh, no, I'm done.
Then we'll sing you off to sleep, you as they're jealous.
Tonight you'll prop your feet up, but for now, Let's eat up
be our guests, be our guests, be our guests Please be our...
Yeah!
Why are you making me sing all these hard songs?
Why
are you making me sing all these hard songs?
Oh wait, uh, I missed, uh... Under the Sea And...
Be our guest, be our guest
Oh my gosh, the whole time I was just thinking of the ride
at Tokyo Disney.
So awesome.
You must be getting a workout tonight.
I am!
Take a break by singing Tequila.
You're so right.
What does Tequila taste like?
I've never had it before.
Rockbiter, thanks for the vibe gifted.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Is it this one?
It's spicy?
Oh no, I'm getting an inch in my body.
I'm getting an inch in my body.
Oh, I'm dancing.
Oh no!
Tequila.
Who are you?
Careful not to strain your voice.
Tequila.
Bo-bo-bo-bo-bo-bo-bo.
Buda, buda, buda, buda, buda.
Yay.
Okay.
I think I'm all warmed up now.
It was to the lovers.
Sitting in the car, listening to blonde, falling for each
other.
Pink and orange skies, feeling super childish.
No Donald Glover.
Miss call from my mother.
Like, where are you at tonight?
Got no alibi.
I was all alone.
With the love of my life She's got glitter for skin My
radiant beam in the night I don't need no light To see you
shine It's your golden hour
I In your golden
Oh We were just two lovers Feet up on the dash, driving
nowhere fast Burning through the summer Radio on blast, make
the moment last She got solar power In its feel like ours
She knew she was the baddest, can you even imagine Falling
like I did for the love She's got glow on her face, a
glorious look in her eyes, My angel of light I was all alone
with the love of my life She's got glitter for skin, my
radiant beam in the night I don't need no light to see you
shine It's your golden
You slow down down In your golden
I forget how long the intro or the outro is
I saw someone else request something earlier That I can sing
Actually I will do my best I will do my best to sing I think
I've only sung this song a lot I hate
to give you satisfaction asking how you're doing now How's
the castle built off people you pretend to care about Just
like you wanted Look at you, cool guy, you got it I see the
parties and the diamonds Sometimes when I close my eyes Six
months of torture you sold as some forbidden paradise I
loved you truly You gotta laugh at the stupidity Cause I've
made some real big mistakes But you make the worst one look
fine I should have known it was strange You only come out at
night I used to think I was smart But you made me look so
naive The way you sold me for parts Is you sunk your teeth
into me Bloodsucker, fame fucker Bleeding me dry like a
goddamn bam
And every girl I ever talked to told me you were bad, bad
news You called them crazy, God I hate the way I called them
crazy too You're so conniving?
How do you lie without flinching?
Oh, what a mesmerizing, paralyzing, fucked up little thrill
Can't figure out just how you do it, God knows I will never
will As girls your age know better, I've made some real big
mistakes But you make the worst ones look fine I should have
known it was strange You only come out at night I used to
think I was smart But you made me look so naive The way you
sold me for parts To me, you're both bloodsucker, fame
fucker, bleeding me dry like a goddamn vampire
You said it was true love, but wouldn't that be hard?
You can't love anyone, cause that would mean you had a heart
I tried to help you out, now I know that I can't Cause now
you think this kind of things I've never understood
I've made some real big mistakes But you make the worst one
look fine I should have known it was strange You only come
out at night I used to think I was smart But you made me
look so naive The way you sold me for parts As you sunk your
teeth into me Bloodsucker, rain fucker, bleeding me dry like
a goddamn vampire.
Yeah!
This is Vampire by Olivia Rodrigo.
Wait, what did I sing after tequila?
Oh, Golden Hour?
And then Vampire?
English?
Olivia?
Not to be mistaken with the other?
Glad you're back, vince.
Since you're not streaming on Friday, could I give an early
happy birthday?
Of course, Table Nome!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Table Nome.
Happy birthday.
Happy early birthday.
Sorry, I won't be here to celebrate on the actual day, but
just play this on the actual day.
Actually, don't even listen right now.
Play it back on the original day.
The original day.
There's actually a song I want to sing.
I've never sung it before.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
Actually, there's a couple songs I wrote down.
I remember someone saying this earlier.
I've never sung this song before, so I'm kind of nervous.
I'll do my best.
Oh.
And you don't seem to understand A shame you seemed an
honest man And all the fears you hold so dear Will turn to
whisper in your ear And you know what they say, I heard you
And you know that it means so much And you don't even feel a
thing I am falling, I am fading I have lost it all And you
don't seem the lying kind A shame that I can read your mind
And all the things I bet I read there Candle-lit smile that
we both share And you know I don't mean to hurt you, but you
know that I mean so much, and you don't even feel the pain.
I am falling, I am fading, I am drowning, help me to
breathe, I am hurting, I have lost it all, I am losing.
Help me to breathe.
I
don't know the ad lips here.
I am falling.
I am failing.
Help me to breathe.
breathe.
I am hurting.
I have lost it all.
I am losing.
Help me to breathe.
I have
lost it all.
I am losing.
Help me to breathe.
Yay.
How do you say the of the song du duvet i know it's french
probably right duvet it's so crazy how this song kind of
blew up recently but as i guess most maybe not maybe not
most people nowadays but um it's the opening of the anime
serial experiments lane which i watched long long long ago
long long long ago duvet like the blanket i don't know
actually maybe let's all love Lane it's because of Lane Lane
Lane Lane serial experiments Lane now okay would love to
hear you sing my first lover by Jillian Welch the movie The
Strangers got me into this song oh the one the creepy song
that like plays over and over again on them can we try
welcome to the black parade let's do that later um thank you
oh my gosh also brick i'm so sorry i just saw your akadono
mint left heaven but she still sings like an angel no thank
you thank you so much i'm sorry i missed it arigato arigato
chew um what was i gonna say uh way to fall i could do way
to fall no i was gonna say something though um harryana
cross i could do that one too maybe if my voice can handle
it i don't remember sorry my whole my whole brain chapel
road h-o-t-t-o-g-o you can take me Heart to go, heart minto.
H-O-T-T-O-G-O Wait, H-O-T-M-I-N-T-O You can take me, heart
minto.
I wonder if there's any Final Fantasy on here.
Final Fantasy.
I sung some a while ago before Oh my god they have sticky
that name But this song is in Jap Wait is it in Japanese?
I'm so curious I'm so curious right now I don't think I've
ever sung a Japanese song on Kairafan So I'm like
There's not an English version of the song Is there?
I
think there's a I'm gonna skip forward I hope it's okay
Actually no This could be one Japanese song
Don't think twice.
The song is so hard.
I wonder if there's Uta Day Hikaru on here.
Oh, I'm thinking of Chikai.
Chikai is really hard.
But don't think twice I can maybe do if it's on here.
Oh, my God.
I can't get the timing.
The sun is in the mirror.
The moon is in the sky.
The stars are flowing, and there are a lot of tears.
I love you.
Part is
so pretty.
Three, four, two, one.
A lot of light is A lot of light The clouds are yellow And
tomorrow
The sky's
Colble Mansion It's a cool mansion It's a great place to
take your hand, take your hand, take your hand, take your
hand, Oh, it's good.
It's your city, It's your heart.
It's in the heart.
I love it.
Your face,
It's so hot.
It's great.
It's good.
Oh my god!
Yay!
I could see it!
Oh my god, so the beginning I was like trying to, I couldn't
remember so much of it.
But then it all came back to me all at once.
I love Final Fantasy 10, 10, 2.
They do have Tata Hikaru on here.
No,
they don't have...
What was Chikai called again?
They don't have it though.
No!
They do have simple and clean though.
A thousand words.
I don't know if they had it though.
Final Fantasy XII songs.
Let me see if they have a thousand words.
no sad do they have what was the other one what can i do for
you
melody's alive no i think that was the only final fantasy
song that they have so sad so sad wait i wonder if we put in
kingdom hearts if kingdom hearts haha did someone say the
door did oh wait so if i put in kingdom hearts the songs
don't show up but if i put in utada hikaru they do eyes on
me i think i sang eyes on me last time
a sanctuary the english one oh my gosh utada hikaru oh there
it is it fixed itself
Excuse me?
In you and I, there's a new land Angels in flight Wonk My
sanctuary, my sanctuary Where fears and lies melt away
I don't think I can sing this one very well, but that's
okay.
I want you fast asleep.
means nothing in you and I there's a new land walk my
sanctuary my sanctuary where fears and lies melt away
Walk.
What's left of me?
Oh,
it's a battleground.
Sorry.
Walk.
It's so cool that they have the lyrics actually backwards.
What?
That's so awesome.
I forgot how hard the song goes.
You show me how to see that nothing is whole and nothing is
broken.
And you and I, there's a new land.
My sanctuary, my sanctuary, where fears and lies melt away.
You've been here for a while.
What's left of me, what's left of me now.
My fears, my lies.
This song is so hard to sing.
I believe that there are just some songs that Uta the Hikaru
can only sing.
Wonk.
Yay.
Request Eyes on Me from Final Fantasy 8.
I can probably find it somewhere.
I will find it.
Let's see.
I have to go to YouTube, though.
I'm pretty sure I did.
Eyes on me, though.
Eyes on me.
Instrumenta.
Is there a...
Oh, here we go.
I think I did this one before.
Sorry, you'll just have to see...
You'll just see...
You'll just see Caravan, but nothing else.
Nothing moving.
Whenever I sang my songs On the stage, on my own Whenever
said my words Wishing they would be heard I saw you smiling
at me Was it real or just my fantasy You'd always be there
in the corner Of this tiny little bar My last night here for
you Same old songs, just once more My last night here with
you Maybe yes, maybe no I kind of liked it your way How you
shyly placed your eyes on me But did you ever know that I
had mine on you Darling so there you are with that look on
your face as if you're never heard as if you're never down I
be the one for you Who pinches you softly But sure If round
is shown then I will know that You are no dreamer
So let me come to you Close as I want to be Close enough for
me To feel your heart beating fast And stay there as I
whisper How I loved your peaceful eyes on me Did you ever
know that I had mine on you?
Darling, so share with me your love if you have enough, your
tears if you're holding back, that's what it is how can i
let you know i'm more than the dress and the voice just
reach me out then you will know that you are not dreaming
Darling, so there you are With that look on your face As if
you're never heard As if you're never down Shall I be the
one for you Who pinches you softly but sure if brown is
shown then I will know that you are no dreamer song is so
long yay oh oh don't listen to that thanks outro youtube
channel youtube channel outro actually another song I want
to sing.
It's not, it is on Kara Fun, but I want to show you,
actually maybe I should just do the Kara Fun version.
Maybe I should do, but it's like, it'll ruin the mood, I
think.
Okay, I'm going to sing it, and then I'm going to show you
the Kara Fun version.
I'm going to sing it, and then I'm going to show you the
Kara Fun version, because it's so funny.
Okay, because I want you to hear it.
I, I don't want you to hear it and like, or see the lyrics
and then be like, what the hell?
And then I sing it and you're like, wait, it's already
ruined.
Okay.
Oh my God, I'm so sorry.
Holy shit.
Song King.
Oh my God.
Sorry.
They had an intro on the YouTube one.
Holy moly.
Oh my God.
I'm so sorry.
My, I'm so sorry.
That hurt me as much as it hurt you guys probably.
I'm so sorry.
Oof.
Okay.
Oh, thank God.
It played it again, but I turned it off.
Ah!
God, sorry.
You can't hear it, but I can.
Shut up!
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Holy.
It's so loud even for me.
Okay.
Okay, I'm going to say...
is like so not that type of song either so it's funny oh you
could hear it a little bit
days and sometimes as if they'll never end sun digs heels to
haunt you but after sunlit days one thing stays the same
rises the moon
Days fade into a watercolor blur Memories swim and haunt you
But look into the lake, shimmering like smoke, rises the
moon Close your weary eyes I promise you that soon the
autumn comes to darken Fading summer skies Breathe, breathe
Breathe Days pull you down just like a sinking ship Floating
is getting harder But tread the water child and know that
meanwhile Rises the moon
Days pull you up just like a daffodil Uprooted from its
garden They'll tell you what you owe But know even so Rises
the moon
Be visited by sleep I promise you that soon the autumn comes
to steal away each dream you keep breathe breathe breathe
i don't i don't want there to be an outro this channel
scares me yay that was rises the moon the moon it's a really
pretty song I think I think there's some other songs I want
to sing we'll go back to carrot fun one of them is I saw
some people requesting carpenters here you go oh why
do birds suddenly appear every time you near just like me
they long to be close to you why do stars fall down from the
sky every time you walk by just like me they long to be
close to you On the day that you were born the angels got
together and decided to create a dream come true So they
sprinkled moonless in your hair and golden starlight in your
eyes of blue That is why girls in the town follow you all
around just like me they long to be close to you
When you were born, the angels got together And decided to
create a dream come true So they sprinkled moon dust in your
hair And golden starlight in your eyes of blue That is why
all the girls in town Follow you all around Just like me,
they long to be close to you.
Just like me, they long to be close to you.
you Ah
Ah Close to you Remember I sing the song I hold my little
baby snake Ah Ah And I sing to him Close to you Ah Ah Close
to you Ah
A cheeky spirit on Twitter told me you are an enjoyer of
cultured ren fan manga and here I am here to say bass.
Also, I forget how beautiful your singing is.
Thank you for the super chat.
Close to you.
I love you little snake.
Okay, go back to standing on my desk as you always are.
I got a snake from a gotcha, a snake figure, and I sing
this.
him every time.
Whether now or in the future, I think it would be real nice
to hear you saying don't speak by no doubt, even if it would
be lethal.
Don't speak by no doubt.
Hopelessly devoted to you from Greece?
I've never sung that before.
Could you sing fine on the outside?
Oh, I can!
Wait, I don't...
Hold on, let me hear the don't speak.
Do I know this song?
You and me We used to be together Every day together Always
I really feel That I'm losing my best friend I can't believe
this could be the end It looks as though you're letting go
And if it's real, my friend don't wanna know Don't speak, I
know just what you're saying So please just stop explaining
And don't tell me cause it hurts And don't speak, I know
it's the
way it's your reasons Don't tell me.
Our memories, they can be inviting.
But some are all, some are all together, might be
frightening.
As we dive, boom, you and I, with my head in my hands, I sit
and cry.
Don't speak, I know just what you're saying.
So please stop explaining.
Don't tell me cause it hurts.
No, no, no, no.
Don't speak.
I know what you're thinking.
And I don't need your reasons.
Don't tell me cause it hurts.
Oh my god, I haven't heard this song forever.
It's not ending.
I gotta stop pretending.
But we are.
knows far.
I have not heard this song in so long, so I don't remember
it very well, I'm sorry.
You and me, I can see us dying, are we?
Don't speak, I know just what you're saying, so please stop
explaining.
Don't tell me cause it hurts.
No, no, no, don't speak I know what you're thinking And I
don't need your reasons Don't tell me cause it hurts Don't
tell me cause it hurts I know what you're saying So please
stop explaining Don't speak, don't speak, don't speak I know
what you're thinking And I don't need your reasons I know
you're good I know you're good I know you're real good Oh
La-la-lash Darling
Yay Let's see I did Um Close to you Don't speak Um for
singing my karaoke song sorry if i um butchered it then hush
hush hush hush push push um uh kiss from a rose oh my gosh
have i ever sung this song before i don't think so
i'm I'm at seal.
No, not seal.
A seal.
I think I'm confusing artist.
You remember me by Jewel.
I don't know if I know that one.
There used to be a grain tower alone on the sea.
You became the light on the dark side of me And love
remained way at your mark as the heart and on the pill But
did you know that when it snows, my eyes become large And
the light that you shine can be seen Baby, I compare you to
a kiss from a rose on the ground Ooh, the more I get of you,
the stranger it feels, yeah.
And now that your rose is in bloom, a line hits the gloom on
the gray.
What does that mean?
A kiss from a rose on the gray.
What's the gray?
I don't understand it.
There's so much a man can't do.
I can tell you so much he can say You will remain my power,
my pleasure, my pain Baby, to me You're like a growing
addiction, I can't even deny Oh God, won't you tell me, is
it the healthy baby?
Oh wait, but did you know that when it snows My eyes become
large and the light that you shine can be seen?
And baby, I compare you to a kiss from a rose on the grave.
Ooh, the more I get a few, the stranger it feels, so yeah.
And now that your rose is in bloom, a light is the gloom on
the grave.
She's basically D.
What do you mean by that?
It's meant to be abstract.
on a queen oh kiss by a rose oh i've never oh oh but all
goes away oh i've been kissed by a rose there is so much a
man can tell wait oh gosh i don't remember what he can say
you remain my power my pleasure my pain I can't remember
this song!
I can't remember!
But did you know that when it snows, my eyes become large
and the light that you shine can be seen?
Baby, I compare you to a kiss from a rose on the grave Ooh,
the more I get a view, the stranger it feels, yeah And now
that your roses in blue A light hushed the gloom on the gray
Yes, I compare you to a kiss from the rose on the gray Ooh,
the more I get a view, the stranger it feels, yeah And now
that your roses in blue Light hits the gloom on the grave.
This isn't about drugs, is it?
Now that your roses in bloom, a light hits the gloom on the
grave.
Drugs, no!
It's about kissing roses.
Roses.
Obviously.
Most common views are either touching the edge of death or
the rose bringing back vibrance to life that was depressive
and gray.
Ah.
See, that sounds so nice.
It's about love, I think.
Yeah.
See?
Gosh, you guys.
It's about love.
Is it about anything?
Who knows?
What time is it?
I've only been, I've sung 22 songs in two hours.
That's so many.
Hold on, I'm going to eat some more of my food.
I hope it's okay.
And let's take a little break.
Let's take a little tiny break.
Music.
Let me eat.
Oh.
Break time.
So I can eat my food.
Yeah, this will be hard cut.
Don't worry.
We're like, I want to go watch something else.
Yeah, I get it.
I don't want you to hear me.
Oh, um.
I'm like eating it so fast.
I'm eating it so fast.
My tummy started to growl, though.
You know what?
Don't watch me eat either.
I'm going to turn around.
There we go.
Now you can't listen to me.
Wait.
Hold on.
I'm going to stay away from my life.
Okay.
I don't...
Probably.
She moves away from the mic to breathe.
Her floor was your lucky number.
Chocolate rain.
Some say...
Is that true that that song is about pooping?
Is it true?
That song is about pooping?
I hope not.
I got some broccoli on my desk.
Into the trash!
There we go.
Think you could sing Six... Wait, it's...
Kiss me by Sixpence none the richer.
Yeah, I can sing that one.
Chocolate rain isn't about pooping, it's not.
I don't know, I just remember hearing that as a kid.
People were like, some stay dry while others feel the pain.
Chocolate rain.
It's about what?
Oh, I think I'm way off.
I
only know that what the chocolate rain...
my bad i didn't mean to be insensitive i just had no idea
i regret my words and actions
i regret my words and actions my words and deeds
fabulous from high school musical too Oh my gosh, I don't
know if I I don't know if I know it very well
That's the one that goes I'm feeling fabulous Fabulous I
don't know it
Is this archived?
I don't know Maybe not anymore
Maybe not anymore Maybe not anymore
No, I'm just kidding.
What was I going to do?
I wonder if someone required...
I wonder if this is on here.
No, I'm going to have to find an instrumental on YouTube.
Let me check if this one works.
Sorry, you're going to hear no music.
I think so.
I don't hear some awful, terrible intro or anything.
So let's do this one.
Okay.
Kaliopi Mori's End of Alive.
There's a karaoke version.
Oh, I don't know, though.
I like that song a lot.
I've never tried singing it.
I'm so nervous to sing to sing other VTuber songs sometimes.
I'll think about it, though.
Maybe one day I'll do, like, a dedicated hollow live
karaoke.
Maybe I'll do a dedicated hollow live karaoke sometime.
Because I've been singing a lot of Stellar Steller.
I've been singing so much, or not singing, but, like
listening to Stellar Stellar so much so Callie won't mind
I'm I don't know I'm afraid of upsetting people so I don't
know I want to if I do upset people I would at least do the
songs justice you know hmm we'll see we'll see okay okie
dokie um I'm not to write a few more of this some of the
requests that i've seen uh that i'm thinking of um actually
now i'm now i can't remember any of you know what let's just
we'll just we'll just play by ear okay oh oh oh i started
playing it but you guys couldn't hear it there we go okay
Learn to be okay with just me, just me, just me, just me,
and I'll be fine on the outside.
I like to eat in school by myself.
anyway so I'll just stay right here right here right here
right here and I'll be fine on the outside And so I just sit
in my room after hours with the moon And think of who knows
my name Would you cry if I died?
Would you remember my face?
Oh, I left home, I packed up and I
asked one day and I laughed I laughed
I sound wine on the outside oh my
loss sometimes I'm confused sometimes I find that I am not
all right and And I cry.
And
I...
So I just sit in my room After hours with the moon And think
of who knows my name Would you cry if I died?
Would you remember my face?
That one's kind of hard to sing.
Mine on the outside.
Yeah.
Let's see.
Another one that people were asking for.
Oh, there was one that I wanted to sing.
How do I...
Oh, it's a...
What's it called?
Hold on.
I have it.
I'm the tippy, tippy, tippy, tippy of my tongue.
Oh.
Maybe if I search this.
Okay.
I've never actually seen Steven Universe before, but I
really like the music.
So I'm going to sing this one next.
If I could begin to be half of what you think of me, I could
do about anything I could even learn how to love when I see
the way you act.
Wondering when I'm coming back, I could do about anything I
could even learn how to love like you.
Love like
you.
I always thought I might be bad, now I'm sure that it's
true, because I think you're so good, and I'm nothing like
you.
you look at you go I just adore you I wish that I knew what
makes you think I'm so special if I could begin to do
something that does right by you I would do about anything I
would even learn how to love when
I see The way you look shaken by how long it took I could do
about anything I could even learn how to love like you
Love me like you
Song is so pretty oh my god Love like you.
BAM!
Yay!
Let's see.
I don't know this other one, though, but I like it.
I know a little bit of it.
I might mess up the middle part.
I'm going to try it anyway.
If I mess it up, sorry.
I was fine with the men who had come into her life now and
again.
I was fine, because I knew that there didn't really matter
until you.
I was fine when you came, and we fought like it was all some
silly game.
Over her, who'd she choose?
All those years I'd never thought I'd lose.
It's over, isn't it?
Isn't it over?
Isn't it?
You won and she chose you and she loved you and she's gone.
It's over, isn't it?
Why can't I move on?
War and glory Reinvention, fusion, freedom Her attention out
in daylight My potential, bold, precise, experimental Who am
I now in this world without her?
Petty and dull with the nerve to doubt her What does it
matter?
It's already done Now I've got to be there for a sign
Isn't it?
Isn't it over?
It's over, isn't it?
You won and she chose you and she loved you and she's gone.
Why can't I move on?
It's so Jover.
It's Jover, isn't it?
Isn't it?
Isn't it Jover?
It's Jover, isn't it?
Isn't it?
Thank you!
I'm on a flight to Colombia!
Wow, how fun!
I want to thank you for inspiring me to visit new places and
get out of my comfort zone!
Shakira or any songs from Enkanto.
Thank you for always being amazing.
I don't know if I know very many Shakira songs that well but
I can't sing Enkanto.
Enkanto.
What's a song that I could sing?
It's Fanta over.
Um...
I think maybe the best thing I could do is we don't talk
about Bruno, maybe.
Down, thank you so much for the 20 Gifted.
Why did you make me cry in the middle of my work?
Don't cry, don't cry, don't cry.
Oh, I only really know we don't talk about Bruno and the
family Madrigal.
But I don't think I could sing that one very well because
it's kind of fast.
I've never sung it before.
We don't talk about Bruno.
I'm going to sing all the parts.
Oh, my God.
That high is really, thank you for the 50s, thank you.
About Bruno, no, no, no.
We don't talk about Bruno.
But it was my wedding day, we were getting ready.
Wait, hold on.
Oh, there.
The cloud in the sky.
My cloud's so loud in the sky.
Bruno walks in with a mischievous grin.
I'm there.
You're telling the story, are am I?
I'm sorry, maybe that go on.
Bruno said it looks like rain What if you tell us?
In doing so he floods my brain I wanna guess the umbrella
Married in a hurricane What a joyous day but anyway We don't
talk about Bruno No, no, no We don't talk about Bruno Hey
Good to live in fear of Bruno's starting stumbling I can
always hear I'm sort of mumbling I associate with, well,
well, yeah I messed it up.
I couldn't remember this.
It's a heavy lift with the gifts so humbling.
Always left a bula in the family fumbling.
Raffling with the prophecies they couldn't understand.
Do you understand?
Seven foot frame.
Rats so long is back.
When he calls your name.
I forgot that part was coming up.
Yeah, he sees your dreams and freaks on your screams.
We don't talk about Bruno, no, no, no, no.
No, we don't talk about Bruno.
He told me my fish would die.
Excuse me.
Stay dead.
He told me I grew a god and just like he said.
Oh, my hair would disappear.
Now look at my head.
No, no.
Your fate is sealed when your prophecy is read.
He told me that the life of my dreams would be promised and
someday be mine he told me that my power would grow like the
grapes that thrive on the vine he told me that the men of my
dreams wouldn't be just out of reach but truth to another
it's like I hear him now it's like I hear him now I can hear
him now.
Hmm, Bruno.
Yeah, about that Bruno.
I really need to know about Bruno.
Give me the truth and the whole truth, Bruno.
Isabella, your boyfriend's here.
Dinner.
He told me that the life of my dreams would be promised and
someday be mine.
He told me that my power would grow on the vine He told me
that the life of my dreams Would be promised and someday be
mine He told me that my power would grow Like the grapes We
talk about Bruno We talk about Bruno
Oh my god This song is so crazy towards the end Blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Thank you for the dough note.
Superman, my gold finger.
Spider-Wars by No Doubt.
Or Centuria by Sublime.
Maybe next time, I don't, I don't know if I, maybe I would
have to hear them, and I would know.
Next time, I will make a note of those.
Bruno.
We don't talk about Bruno.
We don't talk about...
about uh bruno wait we don't talk about we don't talk about
um mint singing bruno scared by roy orbison or not or not
that maybe the phantom of the opera the phantom of the opera
duh the opera which song from phantom of the opera
opera I did all I asked of you last time the phantom mint
phantom of the opera what about the song from over the
garden wall I don't know if it's on here I'll check will he
doji oh I only know one doji song music of the night point
of no return no that song is too sexy How does this go?
High time sharpens, heightens each sensation.
Darkness wakes and stirs imagination.
Silently the senses abandon their defenses.
Helpless to resist the notes I write.
Fork I compose the music of the night.
Is this a song by Phantom?
Slowly, gently, light on furls its splendor, Raspid,
sensuous, tremulous and tender.
Hearing is believing, music is deceiving, hard as lightning,
soft as candle night.
Dare you trust the music of the night?
Your eyes for your calling, tell the truth.
And the truth is what...
Oh my god, my mic is peaking.
See, in the dark, it's easy to pretend.
That is
one way down to me.
Softly, deafly, music shall come.
you hear it, feel it, secretly possess you.
Open up your mind, let your fantasies unwind.
In this darkness which you know you cannot find.
The darkness of the music of the not.
We threw a strange new world, leave all thoughts of the
world you knew before.
Close your eyes and let music set you free.
Oh, not a good thought for us.
With them, you, can you belong to me?
The whining, falling, sweet intoxication
Touching, trusting, savour each sensation Let the dream
begin, let your dream begin darkest i give in to the power
of the music that i write the power of the music of the
night
oh my abs are gonna go to work out oh my diaper i'm like
Oh, I can't.
How long can make my song take flight?
Help me make the music all the...
Wait, hold on, I want to hear that one.
Awesome.
When it says, help me, all I can think of is, help me white
girl.
Hold on.
Music of the...
Yes!
We can go back to Disney.
Music of the night.
I like singing, like, things, obviously, that I like to
sing.
But it's also really fun to sing.
Like, you know, I never...
I sing Phantom of the Opera, I feel, pretty often.
But...
I've never sung Music of the Night before, so it's kind of
fun.
Make a man out of you.
Dun, dun, dun, dun,
dun.
Make a whisper out of you.
Well hi Raiders, thank you!
Let's get down to business To defeat the Huns Did they send
me daughters When I asked for sons You're the saddest bunch
I ever ever met but you can bet before we're through mr.
I'll make a man out of you
down tranquil as a forest but on fire within yeah once you
find your center you are sure to win you're a spineless This
pale, pathetic lot, and you haven't got a clue.
Somehow I'll make a man out of you.
I'm never gonna catch my breath, single by those who knew
me.
Boy was I a fool in school for cutting Jim.
Shut the hell up, this is my part!
This guy's got him scared to death, hope he doesn't see
right through me.
I knew how to swim.
Be a man.
Green must be swift as the coursing rhythm.
With all the force of the great typhoon.
Be a man.
With all the strength of a raging fire.
Mysterious as the dark side of the moon.
Time is racing toward us till the Huns arrive.
He'd my every order and you might survive.
You're unsuited for the rage of war.
So pack up, go home, you're through.
How could I?
Be a man.
We must be swift as a coursing river with all the force of a
great typhoon.
With all the strength of a raging fire, Mysterious as the
dark side of the moon.
Be a man.
We must be swift as the coursing river With all the force of
a great typhoon.
Be a man with all the strength of a raging fire.
Mysterious as the dark side of the moon Yeah!
Oh no, I started to dance again.
Oh no.
I couldn't see who rated me because I think YouTube glitched
and like only showed like a white bar at the top.
So thank you, whoever rated, thank you.
Um, hold on, I need a drink of water.
Da moon!
Okay, that was so fun.
I just want to sing and dance now.
I'll make a man out of you.
Actually, there's another song that I want to do.
But I always fuck up the last part.
Oh, sorry.
I always mess up the last part.
Dancing Queen!
Oh, my God.
Wait, actually, I'll do that instead.
You're so smart.
Oh, my gosh.
Twilight by E-L-O.
Okay, I'll sing that after.
You can dance, you can dancing,
you can dancing,
you gotta look for a king.
And the music's high with a bit of rock music and
everything's
right.
And when you get the chance, you are the dancing queen.
and sweet forever 17 dancing queen feel the beat from the
tambourine oh yeah
oh we'll see that ghost watch that scene digging the dancing
queen a
teaser you turn him on
to you're in the mood for a And when you get the chance, you
are the dancing queen, young and sweet, forever 17.
Dancing queen, feel the beat from the tambourine.
Oh yeah!
Watch that scene, dig in the dancing queen.
I feel like I needed that baby video again.
Hold on, I'm going to pull it up.
I'm going to pull up the baby.
Hold on, where is it?
Where did I put it?
Baby video.
That's me.
Clapping!
Someone requested Twilight by ELO, okay.
This is me.
Dancing to Twilight, ELO.
Um, there it is.
I think I need to put this one...
No, I'll just sing it out the regular key.
Do Linkin Park?
Oh my gosh, I'll do Linkin Park after.
This is a good idea.
The vision's dancing in my mind.
The early dawn, the shades of time.
Twilight's crawling through my window pane.
Am I awake or do I dream?
The strangest pictures I have seen.
Night is day and twilight's gone away.
With your head held high and your silent mind You can do it
to me from the open skies.
It's either real or it's a dream.
There's nothing that is in between.
Twilight, I only meant to dream.
Stay a while Twilight I gave you time To steal my mind Away
your face You disappeared without a trace You brought me
here But can you take me back Inside the image of your light
That now is day and once was night You leave me here And
then you go away
And see the real herbs, the dream there's nothing
matter The twilight
With your head held high and your scarlet light You came
down to me from the open skies And see the real herbs, the
dream There's nothing matters in between Twilight, I only
meant to stay a while Twilight,
only meant to stay a
while This ending always throws me off I like turned around,
I was just like, is something behind me?
My ending is so jarring Yay, that was Twilight Twilight
Twilight Twilight Twilight Thank you for your energy, Minto
Yeah!
I'll sing a few more songs.
Someone said Lincoln Park.
Oh my gosh.
Now I'm like, oh no, I'm going to get into the emo song
mood.
Uh-oh.
I'm going to this stream's never going to end.
I'm going to do my favorite Lincoln Park song, so I hope you
don't mind.
I don't think I'll even be able to sing it well, but...
Please
consume, like opening the wound up
You all assume I'm safe here in my room Unless I try to
start again I don't want to be the one that battles always
choose Cause inside I realize that I'm the one confused I
don't know what's worth fighting for Why I have to scream?
I instigate, say what I don't mean.
I don't know how I got this way.
I know it's not alright.
So I'm breaking the habits.
I'm breaking the habits tonight.
Where's the anime background?
I'm right here!
Clutching my cure.
I tightly lock the door.
I try to catch my breath again Or much more than any time
before I had no options left again I don't want to be the
one that battles always choose Cause inside I realize that
I'm the one confused I don't know what's worth fighting for
But why have to scream I don't know why I instigate I don't
mean.
I don't know how I got this way.
I'll never be alright.
So I'm breaking the habits.
I'm ready
to show you what I mean.
I don't know how I got this way.
I'll never be alright.
So I'm breaking.
This song is so awesome.
Yay!
That was breaking the habit.
From Lincoln Park.
Let's see.
I feel like I sang like the kids-bought version of it
though.
I feel like I sang the kids-bought version of it.
I'm like, I'll break it on the wall!
Or I'll paint it on the wall!
Lilium.
I don't know Latin.
Who's it even on here?
Let's see.
Not on here.
I saw some people say Fleetwood Mac.
Um.
Ugh.
I don't remember which.
Let me try.
Um.
Let biscuit break stuff.
I'm getting there.
Gosh.
Uh.
Getting there, I'm getting there, I'm getting there.
Maybe this one.
It's totally different.
But you know what?
This is all whiplash, so it's fine, right?
This is all whiplash.
Oh, I forgot to add the dancing queen.
Thank you.
I took my love.
I took it down.
I'm the mountain, and I turn around.
Oh my gosh.
And I saw my reflection.
in the snow-covered hills, till the landslide brought me
down.
Oh, mirror in the sky, what is love?
Can the child within my heart rise above?
Can I sail through the change in ocean ties?
the seasons of my life.
Afraid of changing, because I've built my life around you.
But time makes it bolder, even children get older.
I'm getting older, too.
This is not the one I meant to pick, because I don't know it
as well.
But that's okay.
I'm afraid of changing Cause I've built my life around you
But time makes you bolder Even children get older And I'm
getting older too
And if you see my reflection in the snow-covered hills well
the landslide bring it down if you see my reflection in the
snow-covered hills well the landslide bring it down oh the
landslide bring it down hopefully I did it over okay.
Hopefully I did that okay.
Oh, yeah, but landslide.
I'm gonna have to start scooting things up a little bit.
Yay.
That was great.
Thank you.
Thank you for the claps, everybody.
I appreciate it.
Thank you.
Shut up and dance.
I always end dancing.
Bravo brings tears to my boomer eyes.
That was beautiful.
And Sinap, thank you for donating mid-song.
How dare you?
No, just kidding.
Don't worry about it.
I'm sad now.
Don't be sad.
Here's another one.
I'm probably going to botch this one too.
I'm actually, I'm debating whether I want to sing it or not.
I think I'm going to do three more.
I'm going to go to 35.
So.
what about i'm still standing oh i like that one you know
what i'm still standing oh i wrote sanding i'm really glad
you did lansai i'm going to suggest it and turned up
beautifully oh thank you is that elton john oh i needed more
water after this
So it never would But look at me, I'm coming back again I
got
it Yeah I'm still standing I actually am still standing I
put my desk up And I've been standing this whole time I've
been standing since DuckTales No Yes?
I don't know About then I'm still standing Yeah Yeah Yeah,
some people are requesting ghosts.
I'll be honest, Mariana Cross is like, call me a poser.
It's like one of the only songs that I've listened to a
couple of their songs, but it's only, probably the only one
that I can sing so well.
Actually, I'll be right back.
I'm going to go get some water, like super duper fast, super
duper quick.
I'm like, when I say it's quick, I'm going to be like quick,
quick.
So don't, don't, don't go anywhere.
Why are you guys crying?
What happened?
Why are you crying?
Hmm.
Someone said so no snake eater.
I don't know.
I have three songs left.
What are you talking about?
I have several songs left.
I have songs left, okay?
Oh my gosh.
I need to get ready for tomorrow.
Wait, I need to get ready for this weekend.
Oh, shoot.
Okay, I just noticed the time.
Okay.
I have...
Wait, two songs left.
I can do three if I feel like it.
Okay, let's do Snake Eater now, then.
Um...
Well, I have to find the one that is good.
Okay.
Uh-uh.
What a thrill With darkness and silence through the night
What a thrill I'm searching and I'll melt into you What a
fear in my heart But you're so supreme I give my life Enough
for honor
In my time There'll be no one else Crime is the way I fly to
you
I'm still in a dream Snake eater
Someday you go through the rain And someday you feed on a
tree from It's ordeal, the trial to survive For the day we
see new light I give my life not for wrong
In my time There'll be no one else Crime It's the way I fly
to you I'm still in a dream.
Snake it all.
I'm still in a dream.
Thank you, Andy Moray, your karaoke oh sorry the phantom x
oh perfect you're a phantom too
snake snake snake eater sneak sneak eater okay i know what
the next three songs will be
thank you guys for the super chats oh my gosh youtube is
like really breaking holy cow
Wait.
Oh.
Hold on.
Everything's breaking.
No.
Don't break, please.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Slade, once again, Queen.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Oh, my gosh.
Never get tired of hearing you singing that.
I'm glad.
I'll never get tired of singing it.
I don't know if I'm going to be able to sing this next one
because I think my throat is already borked and
so you want me to send you the kazoo instrumental when I'm
done oh my god yes of course break it more don't worry break
break is happening but you know what I'm gonna sing this
anyway because I like this song actually hold on wait but
but wait I don't want to do it here Wait, wait!
Wait!
There was actually a version I saw that said it had some
special stuff.
Hold on.
Hold on, sorry.
You could just pretend it's playing, right?
You could just be like, yeah.
Yeah.
Um, Okay, hold on.
Let me check this real quick.
Oh.
Oh, it sounds like poo-poo.
Okay, never mind.
I'm going to do this version.
Okay.
We were speeding together down the dark avenues.
But besides all the stardom, all we got was booze.
But through all the sorrow, we've been riding high.
And the truth of the matter is I never let you go, let you
go.
We were scanning the cities, walking to greater do's.
But besides all the glamour, all we got was bruise.
But through all the sorrow, we were riding high.
And the truth of the matter is I never let you go, let you
go.
You go down just like Holy Mary, Mariana, Mariana Cross.
Not just another bloody Mary, Mariana, Mariana Cross.
If you choose to run away with me, I will tell you, tickle
you entirely and i see nothing wrong with that
we were searching for reasons to play by the rules but we
quickly found out it was just for fool not for all the
sorrow we'll be riding high and the truth of the matter I'll
never let you go, let you go
Ah!
You go down just like Holy Mary, Mariana, Mariana Cross Not
just another bloody Mary, Mariana, Mariana You go down just
like Holy Mary, Mariana, Mariana, Mariana, Mariana, Your
beauty never ever scared me Mariana, Mariana Cross If you
choose to run away with me I will tickle you internally And
I see nothing wrong With that
Nothing wrong
Oh gosh, you know Sometimes people would end their sets
strong maybe with their most powerful song, but instead I'm
just going to end everything where I, you know, I don't
sound the best, but I just go crazy with it.
Like this next one.
It's just one of those days when you don't want to wake up.
Everything is fucked.
Everybody sucks.
You don't really know why, but you want to justify ripping
someone's head off.
No human contact.
And if you interact, your life is on contract.
Your best bet is to stay away, Motherfucker!
It's just one of those days It's all about he says, she says
bullshit I think you better quit, let shit slip Or you'll be
leaving with a bad limp!
It's all about the he says, she says bullshit I think you
better quit, talkin' that shit It's just one of those days,
feeling like a freight train First one takes a plane, leaves
with a blood stain Down right, I'm a maniac, you better
watch your back
It's to stay away, motherfucker!
I think you better quit!
Let's shit play by the means and she says bullshit!
What?
So come and get it!
I feel like shit My suggestion is to keep your distance
Cause right now I'm dangerous!
We've all felt like shit And been treated like shit All
those motherfuckers That wanna step up?
Chainsaw!
And if my day keeps going this way, I just might break
something tonight.
I'm back at chainsaw.
I'll skin your ass right.
Talking that shit.
So come and get it.
Yay!
Oh wait, I already wrote it.
Uh, I gotta cross.
Break stuff.
And now the last live, last, last, last song.
Oh, I accidentally hit my mic when I was, when I was like
headbanging.
Whoopsie.
Well, thanks for being here for my karaoke, everybody.
I have one last song, and I hope you liked Break Stuff.
I know people have been asking for it a lot for some reason,
but I hope it, um i hope it uh was your expectations wait i
hope it i hope it lived up to your expectations you went
kind of crazy with that one
it's such a good song to just let it all out you know you
know yeah thanks for the gift and you guys thank you for the
thank you for the the donuts, thank you for this every time.
So I really appreciate it.
Thank you.
Hold on.
I'm afraid of how that sounded, to be honest, but I'm afraid
of how that sounded.
I'm just, sometimes I listen back on my karaoke's to see
like, oh, I should adjust this or change that or whatever,
whatever.
I don't think I'm going to listen back to this one.
Okay.
Actually, that's 35 songs.
Maybe we should keep it at 35.
An even number.
Not even, but, you know, a clean number.
A clean number.
Just wait until you see me sing that song in 3D.
I think.
I think it might be, you know.
Might be really funny.
to watch.
Oh, man.
So, oh, my chat just broke.
Okay.
What you got against 36, huh?
Okay, fine.
I guess we'll just do it.
Even though my throat hurts a little bit.
What?
My throat hurts?
That'd be crazy.
No, I can keep going.
I can keep going.
The emo anthem has gun and I was a young ghost my father
took me into the city to see a marching band he said son
when you grow up would you be the savior of the broken the
beaten and the damned he said will you defeat them Your
demons and all the non-believers The plan that they have
made Because one day I'll leave you Mint Phantom To lead you
in the summer To join the Black Parade
Feel like I should go Do it all, the rise upon the bodies in
the streets And when you're all, we'll carry on
Depends you reeling from decimated dreams Your misery and
hate will kill us all Into
the end we'll hear the call The
pointed faces of your peers
I'm gonna show my scar, give a tear For all the broken,
I'm not a hero Just a ghost I have to sing this song Just a
man We'll carry
I salute to you all Thank you for watching Thank you for
hanging out with me I'll see you guys in a couple days But
thank you for listening Thank you, thank you, thank you
I need a shower Awesome, mean, bye
bye bye bye Thank you, thank you Bye bye Bye Oh, how do I?
There we go.
My child is so broken.
Come on, you're fresh.
I didn't even see what you guys are.
Thank you for the Hakka-champa!
Break me, thank you!
Oh my gosh, thank you so much.
Thank you guys.
Otsu min-tol!
Eat a-lashai!
Bust-o-tubustin!
Oh my gosh, I didn't even see Bustin.
Valentine, thank you for the 50 gifted!
David Steele, thank you for the 50 gifted!
Holy cow, you guys.
Oh my gosh, Valentine, thank you for the- I said earlier.
Yeah.
Oh, watch out.
Thank you.
I'm sorry.
I'm just peeking at the top.
Wait.
Oh, there's our
voice.
I love your voice so much.
You make my day happier.
Thank you.
I always do.
I always end up doing Welcome to the Black Parade.
My, I'm like, my voice is just so bl-bl-bl-bl-bl-bl-bl.
But,
way of saying, I just shouldn't.
Oh my God.
I can't even.
Oh no, I can't even end the stream.
Uh-oh.
Yo.
YouTube is broken.
Forever stream.
Thank you guys.
Oh, Rick.
Thank you for the vending.
Thank you!
Thank you so much, Casey.
Thank you for the vibe.
Thank you guys.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Bye, bye, bye, bye, boy, boy, boy, boy, boy, boy, boy, boy,
boy, boy, boy, boy,